llegó el momento de hablar de economía y
por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero Juan Pablo lukumi Juan Pablo
qué tal todo muy bien Buenas noches Juan
Pablo empezamos con el actual panorama
de inflación que pronósticos tiene el
fondo monetario internacional para el
próximo año pues Andrés la directora del
prestamista internacional dijo que en
vez de mejorar el panorama va es a
empeorar con esto el fmi planea reducir
la semana que viene su pronóstico de
crecimiento mundial a tan solo el 2,9%,
mientras dejo quieta la previsión del
3,2% para 2022 según su directora
cristalina George lleva la proyección
para 2023 se debe a los impactos
causados por la pandemia del cómic 19 la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania y los
desastres climáticos en todos los
continentes Esto fue lo que dijo
tenemos un mensaje para todos los países
que la política monetaria y fiscal
tienen que ir de la mano y que tienen
que tener mucho cuidado en Cómo
implementan la política fiscal que
corporal y que sea focalizada por qué
Porque de lo contrario solo están
alimentando más inflación conocemos la
situación de 2008 lo que tenemos hoy es
un sector bancario mucho más fuerte que
el que teníamos entonces Juan Pablo
Estados Unidos sigue en la búsqueda de
aumentar su competitividad en el mercado
de semiconductores Andrés este jueves el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
estuvo en Nueva York visitando una de
las instalaciones de la reconocida
empresa multinacional de tecnología y
consultoría International business
machines Corporation más conocida como
IBM Pues esta empresa planea invertir 20
mil millones de dólares Durante los
próximos 10 años para la fabricación de
semiconductores Inteligencia artificial
y computación cuántica byden y la
vicepresidenta cámara Harris han
impulsado Durante los últimos meses la
fabricación de chips para competir
contra la oferta asiática en agosto del
mismo bailen firmó el proyecto de ley de
chips y ciencia financiado con un monto
de 52 mil millones de dólares escuchemos
lo que dijo el mandatario en la reunión
de hoy
Dónde está escrito que no podemos
liderar la fabricación en el mundo no sé
dónde está escrito eso y esa es una de
las cosas que va a cambiar la ley chips
la ley que va a construir un futuro y un
orgullo amigos necesitamos fabricar
estos chips aquí en Estados Unidos para
reducir los costos diarios y crear
empleos estadounidenses bien remunerados
no confíen en mi palabra escuchen a los
líderes de IBM y de todo el país Juan
Pablo dice Abre otro capítulo más en la
historia de Twitter versus el
multimillonario y lo musk porque ahora
se aplazó el juicio Así es Andrés
volvemos a hablar del tema la jefa del
tribunal de cancillería desde la web
dijo este jueves que el multimillonario
y los musk y Twitter tienen hasta el 28
de octubre para cerrar el trato
recordemos que esta semana most revivió
el acuerdo original de compra de la red
social por 44 mil millones de dólares
con esta nueva fecha de Corte ahora sí
pues esperemos que ambas partes se
supone que deben llegar al punto final
de esta pero si no sucede que pues no
nos sorprendería el tribunal dijo que
entonces ambas partes deberán ser
citadas en noviembre seguramente una
historia quedará mucho de que hablar
Juan Pablo vamos con la cifra del día la
cifra del día 350 dólares costará el
primer reloj inteligente de Google para
que saldrá el próximo 13 de octubre el
precio de este aparato tecnológico
entrará al mercado con 100 dólares más
que el modelo de menor costo de Apple
además de tener serias limitaciones para
usuarios con teléfonos Android ya
veremos qué tan competitivo será este
dispositivo justo cuando la inflación ha
llevado a las personas a comprar menos
lujos y enfocarse cada vez más en lo
estrictamente necesario no sé si usted
se lo compraría vamos a ver vamos a
verlo porque cada vez está más caros
estos dispositivos Así es Y bueno
cerramos con indicadores Juan Pablo
cerramos con los indicadores en Wall
Street las acciones en su mayoría
cerraron a la baja luego de conocerse un
informe que reportó que más
estadounidenses solicitaron subsidio
empleo la semana pasada se espera que
mañana las decisiones de los
comerciantes estén determinadas por los
datos mensuales del mercado laboral que
publicará el gobierno siguiendo la senda
de Estados Unidos las acciones europeas
tuvieron una segunda sesión de pérdidas
con sus tres principales indicadores a
la baja mientras que las bolsas de
nuestra región cerraron en terreno mixto
luego de que la bolsa de Sao Paulo
acumulará cinco ganancias consecutivas
la bolsa de valores de México avanzó un
1,05% y la bolsa de comercio de Buenos
Aires cerró este jueves con un descenso
del
1,41%. Juan Pablo lukumi con la
información económica Gracias por
acompañarnos seguimos con más aquí en
directo América